okay tick-tock stock influencers are
following or telling the stock picks of
members of congress for gains and views
according to an npr article from tuesday
uh remember we covered uh the twitter
outrage surrounding nancy pelosi's
husband trading options back on episode
1242 in that case pelosi's husband was
caught buying millions of dollars of
call options or betting the stock would
go up on amazon a few weeks before the
department of defense canceled the 10
billion dollar jedi cloud computing
contract that had been given to
microsoft what amazing timing for the
pelosi family uh the rumors of this news
sent amazon stock to an all-time high of
over 3 700 a share and pelosi's husband
made millions just on that one trade the
account unusual wells on twitter which
is an interesting one to follow uh
reveal pelosi's husband had a string of
success with call options which were
curiously linked to regulatory news
these included
tesla clause before the biden
administration set a goal to have half
of all new vehicles sold by 2030 to be
electric
and microsoft calls right before they
were given a 22 billion dollar
government contract to supply us army
troops with ar headsets for training
once all of this information was made
public people on social media were
mostly outraged however some of these
tick tockers decided to start telling
the pelosi investments npr quoted
tick-tockers saying
shouts out to nancy pelosi the stock
market's biggest well ceo watch list on
tick tock said she knew and you would
have known if you had followed her
portfolio i'm at the point where
if you can't beat him join them chris
josephs on tiktok to be clear these two
accounts make money by selling stock
tips and alert so their business model
is a date of business like pitchbook or
smp so
they're maybe they're just being cheeky
or funny what these uh tick-tockers
don't emphasize is that there's a delay
on these disclosures that can be up to
45 days when a congress person actually
makes the trade these are called ptr's
you may have heard periodic transaction
reports for example in her august 20th
ptr uh it reported trades pelosi made as
early as july 13 37 days before so
you might be trailing when you're
telling by too long to actually make a
great trade
this info is a good data point but you
aren't actually able to replicate the
portfolio in real time hedge funds
always have to report their trades but
that doesn't mean you can copy them for
example
in 2020 bill ackman made a massive short
that generate 2.6 billion by buying
complex out of the money credit
protection and high yield bond indexes
but if you copy this trade when you
heard about it you would have lost
almost 27 million according to the story
and so as i mentioned in 1242
correlation does not equal causation or
cases uh the solution i proposed was a
once per year trading window for all
elected officials and their spouses so
let me know your thoughts on that if
you're in government i think you should
be
maybe limited to quarterly or maybe
twice a year indexing of your uh
funds and i think
congress people should be paid
you know similar to ceo pay maybe 500
000 a year maybe even uh you know for
senators a million dollars a year why
not pay them top rates so that
really talented people would take those
jobs and be able to afford a nice house
you know
and then working in government
would uh pay to measure it with working
in the corporate world right would you
be opposed to
a senator making you know what are there
two senators from each state so
if they got paid a million dollars a
year we'd spend 100 million on centers
seems like a good idea to me okay the eu
is planning on mandating that all new
smartphones and electric devices include
a usb
c charging point according to the verge
of the european commission which is the
executive arm of the eu as you know
proposed plans to force electronics
manufacturers to put a usbc charging
port on all new devices this mandate
obviously is going to impact apple the
most since their iphones still use
lightning connections
obviously apple has been moving away
from them ipads have been using usbc for
a while
the verge notes that under this mandate
customers will also be given the option
to purchase devices without a charger
which is critical and i think this is my
hot take on this the default should be
no charger
we all have usb chargers everywhere
just like when you go into a grocery
store in america or in europe they
assume you've brought your own bags with
you and if you want a paper bag or a
plastic bag or a reusable you have to
pay for them that's how we should be
with chargers now usbc all the way and
if you want to charge it you pay extra
the default box should come without a
charger that would be better for all of
us these things are littering
everybody's house and we all pay for it
so let's take that out and let's have
less packaging and less waste
now remember in october of last year we
covered apple announcing they would
start removing charges as the default
when you purchase your new iphone
starting with iphone 12
that was episode 1123 we had a lot of
fun with
apple
explaining to us what a great feature
this was but you know they're not wrong
um it is very wasteful and so the verge
also notes that this proposal only
covers devices that use a wire not
wireless chargers for me
um i think what's happening here is that
in the two-year grace period which the
eu uh is talking about if this mandate
actually happens uh you know it's gonna
there's gonna be a 24-month uh to comply
grace period i think what this is all
about is apple's going to get rid of the
port i think there'll be no usbc port on
apple devices i think they're going to
go
with and i know this is going to be hard
for data but for charging maybe they'll
just have a magsafe type thing where the
magsafe will also do data
so i bet you there's some usbc magsafe
wireless connectivity solution coming
and then maybe in 24 months when you buy
a phone they took the microphone jack
out so we don't have headphones anymore
i think they do the same with uh the
usbc charger it'll just be like the only
holes on your phone are gonna be
things like um
audio and speakers so
this is absolutely fantastic i think and
a great idea
the the next piece of this i think also
is i don't know if you've been following
uh this uh charger that is coming from
ikea
i don't know how to pronounce this word
s j o m a r k e
quay marque
is a wireless charger that ikea is sold
out of it's a forty dollar qui or
wireless charger you know the qi is a
wireless charger you can see an image on
the screen uh showing it basically all
of the desks we buy in the future are
going to have
this qi charging built into the desk and
you're going to be able to drill right
underneath it and it'll probably come
with one of these by default soon and
it's going to be absolutely awesome it's
pretty obvious to me as i've pointed out
with ikea now selling this and making it
a big focus
that
every device you buy every side table is
going to have a plug and you're going to
plug that side table in and that side
table is going to have multiple charges
on it
and there'll be some little
dot or led built into every desk or
charger to lay your phone your laptop
your ipad onto it and have it charged or
even your air pods or my favorite pixel
buds i think pixel buds the 99 version
much better than apple airpods so it's a
great future
[Music]
okay it's time for another rcrout deal
of the week right now you can join our
crowd's investment in consumer physics
according to the deal memo consumer
physics has developed the first portable
lab-grade device that can analyze
material at a molecular level that
sounds fascinating this helps farmers
boost production improve efficiency and
minimize waste consumer physics has
grown revenue 100 percent year over year
and is used by over 50 global enterprise
customers according to their deal memo
and speaking of growth do you wish you
were in early on some of the best
performing ipos of 2019 and 2020 well
our crowd investors were and now you can
join them with our crowd accredited
investors can invest directly easily and
most importantly early our crowd
investors have benefited from companies
ipo like beyond me or companies being
bought by folks like intel nike
microsoft oracle and my personal
favorite uber
so here is your call to action our
crowds accredited investors have already
invested over one
billion dollars in growing tech
companies if you're an accredited
investor you can join our crowd for free
at our
crowd dot com slash twist twist and
review the current deal memos there's no
payment involved until you decide to
invest that's ourcrowd.com twist to sign
up for free